robots uh what I do I like to build
robots I like to program them to me a
robot is something that's a machine and
it somehow senses the world and then it
computes thinks about what the sensors
tell us and then it acts in the world
there are number of years building
robots stop right in unstructured
environments we've been building in with
three different levels of control the
primitive level where the motors and and
sensors operate a skills level where
they have basic sort of skills then a
behavior level which gives them
behaviors like you know going through a
mountain pass finding some dirt on the
floor to clean up we are mechanism if we
are machines then in principle at least
we should be able to build machines out
of other stuff which are just as as
alive as we are eternally grateful to
safety interactive ultimately doing
stuff with us and partner with us this
is going to be important in our old age
we're gonna have more robotics help and
assistance we're not there yet but I
think we're making good progress towards
it